and face-to-face Huddle's with the
candidate at a downtown hotel candidate
also reportedly called chris Christie
today said to be a finalist as well if
you're at all confused about where Trump
stands on this decision don't worry the
candidate cleared it up today in an
interview with bret baier a fox news
level of receptivity that I've had here
is incredible and the governor's been
he's been amazing so we'll see what
happens Newt Gingrich is coming in today
to see me here is by the way down to
know I tell you chris Christie somebody
have liked a long time he's a total
professional he's a good guy by the way
a lot of people don't understand that
but I'm narrowing it down i mean i'm at
three potentially for but in my own mind
i probably am thinking about to john
i've been on the grand all day trying to
follow the follow the bouncing ball from
indianapolis from where you are in
Cleveland where whoever Trump will
accept the nomination next week probably
where does the running mate search stand
well I think it funnily enough after all
the drama of today with the pence
morning where we all thought wow you
know maybe Pence is just the guy then we
learned that sessions and Gingrich were
also on the way to indiana that the
family had met with christie earlier
that Christie was on the phone with
Trump today I think we are not that far
from where we work 24 hours ago we
talked about it on the show which is to
say I believe we have short list now and
the short list is three people Gingrich
Christie Pence and maybe sessions but
but it doesn't seem like there's much to
go on there even though he's there with
you in Indiana so we had a three short
list of three and Trump doing final gut
checks here on who he actually wants to
run with I think sessions is being done
at this point largely as a courtesy I
think the other three are somewhat I
play the the thing I've been saying for
the last 24 hours i think is still true
and a number of Trump aids who've heard
me say it on television has said attaboy
you're right on this if he goes with his
head if he goes with the safe thing the
thing that we unite the conservative
movement the thing that would allow him
to be at the top of the ticket and not
have risked a running mate who would
cause distractions he'll go with he'll
go with Governor pence if
however he goes with the people he still
feels more comfortable with even after
this time with pence he'll go with
either Gingrich or Christie one thing we
don't know is is the vetting issues and
whether he's shying away from either
Christie or Gingrich both of whom have
known things in their dossiers it could
be distractions so both those guys can
cause distractions either by what they
say once they were picked or by their
backgrounds and we just don't know how
heavily Trump is weighing that we do
know that the balance of recommendation
to him amongst people around him is
weighted more towards pence than the
other two right there's some sense in
particular Paul Manafort likes the idea
of pence and we've discussed already
what the assets here are Trump still
needing to consolidate support among
Republicans still having some problems
doing that with conservatives Pence
giving him a good card to play with
conservatives and building up some bona
fides there Paul Ryan today made a
comment about how he'd like to be
reassured that Trump is a genuine
conservative so you can see the argument
there for pence but in the end as you
know mark the question of you know a
candidate a nominee looking into the
eyes of the people who he would not just
be putting on the ticket as a cohort on
the road and in a campaign setting but
also who they would like to govern with
if they become president nited states is
a huge thing that gut check really
matters and maybe for Trump more than
others he doesn't seem like a guy who's
afraid of distractions to me on the
basis of halley's campaign so far so
maybe those the distraction factor won't
matter so much and he'll end up just
saying screw it I want to be with
Christie I want to be with Gingrich
they're more my kinds of guys I think he
likes his own distractions maybe not
that about this does show the closeness
he has to his family the very public way
in which his family's involved in this
decision something I've never seen at
this level right all right new details
are out at this hour about the lineup at
the upcoming democratic national
convention in philadelphia elizabeth
warren michelle obama bernie sanders all
expected to speak on monday night the
first night of the convention two nights
later President Obama will take the
stage that is all we know but amazingly
it's a hell of a lot more than we know
about the Republican convention which
starts here in Cleveland in just five
days reports are the family will play a
big role in that
ted cruz paul ryan mitch mcconnell and
scott walker will all be speaking but
after nearly a week of daily promises
that the full convention schedule will
be released we ain't got it and this
comes amid widespread concerns about the
lack of organization logistics and
security to deal with tens of thousands
of demonstrators on the streets of
Cleveland so mark considering all of
this how likely do you think it is that
the Republican National Convention is
going to be a total fustercluck well
look they are well behind in terms of
what they said publicly and according to
our reporting what's going on behind the
scenes and slotting a convention that
begins in just a few days on the other
hand this is an area where I think Trump
can and the Trump operation can kind of
defy gravity as long as they fill the
time on the stage as long as stuff
happens every day that feeds the beast
that keeps the action moving in the room
they'll be okay and I and it's you know
it's not that much programming it's not
24 hours of programming but it is a high
wire thing here and they are a little
bit in danger of falling off the wire
yes and look the big caveat and I don't
think you're going to disagree with me
when I say this the big caveat here is
our the security issues and what happens
on the streets of Cleveland because
given what has happened in America over
the course of the last week images of
chaos images of disordered images that
could get worse than just chaos and
disorder that could involve violence
those kinds of images could quickly
overwhelm anything going on on the
convention stage over the course the
next week and if that happens this could
really be a mess not just in terms of
the television production but
politically for Donald Trump and his
chances to become an ex-president nited
states you know there's not much they
can do about that they could look if
they had more time and there was more
bandwidth amongst the High Command there
who's spending an extra amount of time
now obviously on this running mate
search they could be coordinating with
the Secret Service and local police and
in a more way that might give people
more confidence but just go back to the
schedule inside the hall you know
picking the speakers is the first step
you gotta then figure out what order
people are speaking in you got to
coordinate their presentations you don't
want another Clint Eastwood situation so
they're they're taking a risk here but
as I said this is an area where Trump
showmanship and his family may be able
to paper over which could be for a
normal campaign and existential crisis
moving on now almost a week after the
Dallas shootings that killed five police
officers Hillary Clinton invoked Abraham
Lincoln's famous house divided speech
today with her own plea for national
unity and remarks at the old Illinois
State Capitol earlier today her speech
which came a day after President Obama
and President Bush spoke at that
memorial service for the Dallas officers
urged Americans to appreciate the
difficult work that police do and also
called for quote ending the systemic
racism that plagues our country then
just after Clinton pleaded guilty for
sometimes stoking political tensions on
the campaign trail herself she took aim
had her general election opponent as
someone in the middle of a hotly fought
political campaign I cannot stand here
and claim that my words and actions
haven't sometimes fueled the
partisanship that often stands in the
way of progress so I recognize I have to
do better to in times like these we need
a president who can help pull us
together not split us apart and that is
why I believe Donald Trump is so
dangerous he says that if he doesn't win
in November we and again I quote won't
even have a country anymore America is
not going to continue to survive I do
not know what he's talking about this
man is the nominee of the party of
Lincoln we are watching it become the
party of Trump and that's not just a
huge loss for our democracy it is a
threat to it shawna Clinton campaign
painted these in advances major remarks
Clinton's first speaking since Donald
Trump declared himself a couple days
writing now is the law and order
candidate so in the ongoing story about
how both candidates have responded to
last week's shooting had to Clinton do
well look what she is trying to do it
seems pretty clear is to beat be the
candidate if there's an optimistic
candidate and a pessimistic candidate
she wants to be the candidate of
optimism guarded optimism realistic
optimism but optimism and she wants to
paint Trump as both a divider and also
someone who traffics in the kind of
apocalyptic rhetoric that has sometimes
is appealing to certain segments of the
electorate but in the end does not
generally and in fact I can't think of a
time it ever has won a general election
she's trying to put herself on the side
of light and him on the side of dark I
think she she framed it relatively well
from her point of view politically today
doesn't mean that trumps message isn't
still powerful but she's taking out some
pretty clear ground you know people talk
all the time I had Trump won't
acknowledge any mistakes and and an
error and Clinton's not too far off that
you know she she said her emails were a
mistake but she didn't really say what
about it was a mistake for her did it
say today and I thought a heartfelt way
but also a shrewd tactical way that
she's been part of you know dialogue
that might be considered divisive I
think that's smart I think that that her
argument in the end about Trump is he's
unreasonable and I'm reasonable and I
think that was a pretty big concession
to make let's see though if she can keep
this tone up if this is a one-off given
the veep stakes and everything else
that's going on I'm not sure the speech
will break through for very many voters
again unless she sustains the tone and
the ideas in other high-profile venues
look I got to say you can't really know
the answer this question in advance but
right now especially just still less
than a week away from all the stuff that
happened last week in Baton Rouge in
Minneapolis and then and then in in
Dallas I just sense there are a lot of
people the country want a unifying
figure not a divisive figure and that
Hillary Clinton's betting that she could
be the unifier in contrast to trump all
right when we come back Donald Trump and
his
picking up momentum in battleground
state polls the what where why and how
of all that right after this
you
welcome back we saw battleground state
pull tsunami today that tells a fairly
consistent story Donald Trump gaining
ground on Hillary Clinton in those
battleground states new NBC Wall Street
Journal marys surveys show Trump tied
with Clinton in Ohio where he trailed
her by six points a couple of months ago
Clinton is still ahead in states like
Colorado where a Monmouth poll has her
up by 13 and Wisconsin were a marquette
poll has her up by six but Trump has
closed the gap in other states including
the key battleground state of Florida
where Quinnipiac University poll has
them ahead 42 to thirty-nine percent
that is an 11-point swing in Trump's
direction from less than a month ago
yesterday we told you about a Bloomberg
politics slice poll that showed clinton
with a big lead among college educated
voters something that doesn't usually
happen for democrats so mark just look
at all these polls ours from yesterday
and the ones that have come out today
what are the realities and implications
that you see of these numbers well look
people are going to have to get used to
there being a difference between the
national polls in the state polls for a
variety of reasons i think that the
reality of the existence of these polls
is a great for Trump on the eve of the
convention it allows him to feel like
he's got momentum and argued to the
delegates where there might be some
wavering this guy can win 270 electoral
votes so get in line and I think for the
Clinton folks they're not happy about it
on one level another level they continue
to believe that their biggest challenge
is getting Democrats donors activists
volunteers to believe this is a loser
will race and to be energizing the way
they're going to need them to be in
order to make it a winnable race yeah
look the other reality here seems to be
in a case in the case of many of these
polls may possibly all they were
conducted in the wake of the komi ruling
last week that she was not going to
recommend any kind of charges against
her over the email controversy and then
you took her the woodshed even as he let
her off the hook and it seems as though
for some number of voter
commis criticisms of Clinton have sunk
in because you can see that in all of
these states are virtually all of them
Trump has gained some ground that's the
big takeaway here in these battleground
states and that it seems to have we
can't tell causation but at least in
terms of timing it seems as though the
komi decision although giving her
sparing her from the existential threat
of prosecution may have taken some at
least temporary toll on her poll
standing yeah and it does show again the
causality is this a way to unpack it but
if it is true that these polls represent
an accurate notion the Trump's doing
better and if it's the case that the
komi thing was a factor which probably
was then you have to say the press may
be overemphasized Trump's failure in his
speeches to take advantage of the coma
thing the coming thing may have happened
all on its own and Trump's instincts
were correct he didn't need to talk as
much about it as his critics said he did
in order for it to have an impact on the
voters well of course on the other hand
you could argue that if he had made a
consistent talking point out it but Ned
driven the message he would gotten even
more of a bounce out of these polls so
you could to them you could argue that
you could argue that yeah all right now
to that spat on going between Donald
Trump and Supreme Court Justice Ruth
Bader Ginsburg it has continues to gain
steam it's been a few days since Justice
Ginsburg told The Associated Press and
later the New York Times that she didn't
want to even think about the possibility
of Trump in the White House talked about
maybe moving overseas on Monday she told
CNN legal analyst Joan Baku pick the
Trump was quote a faker and called him
at for not releasing his tax returns
Trump like many Republicans including
speaker that has Paul Ryan called those
comments inappropriate but the only the
Republican frontrunner went as far as to
send a midnight tweet about this matter
saying quote Justice Ginsburg of the US
Supreme Court has embarrassed all while
making very dumb political statements
about me her mind is shot resign John is
it a good idea for Trump to pick this
fight with the notorious RBG well I
think look well I think we can probably
agree I actually don't know whether we
agree but I think we might that it was
really unusual for Ginsburg to do what
she did and I think probably
inappropriate it's I don't think
definitely an appropriately
inappropriate repudiated by some
Democrats in this partisan period that's
extraordinary and if a Republican if a
Republican Justice did that do a
democratic candidate you know if you I
think peden if you look if you let me
finish yeah if you let me finish so i
was going to say i was going to say
exactly the same thing you were so we're
on the same page about that but the
question is whether Trump gets much
benefit out of attacking Ginsburg in the
way that he's attacking her I again it's
one of these things where I think of
Trump in a sober way where to call
attention and say what you just said and
I just said everyone in the world not
everyone in the world everyone in the
world who's not hopelessly partisan
would say you know Donald Trump has a
point there but then to say that
Ginsburg is like lost her mind that's I
think a little bit it's just a taste
like it's like a child kids fighting on
a schoolyard and it kind of plays into
the notion that Trump's temperament
maybe not be that great again he could
do it he could make the same point
without having to attack her purse but
it it but if you're from the school of
thought that says a lot of what this
election is going to be a bad is using
the cord they energize your base I think
it's good for Trump even to do it this
way because you just you just wants to
get the personalize the notion that the
Liberals on the Supreme Court need to be
replaced by conservatives and this is
going to get attention it's very hard
both sides always try to make the court
an issue it's very hard to do this
allows him to glom onto it again
probably not appealing to that many
people in the center but he does have
some people on left criticizing Ginsburg
and I think that helps his cause no
matter how he takes it up I do think we
should just note it's an incredible
fight something we've never seen before
amazing this packet for Jason entering
Trump just an just amazing all right up
next we had two all-star Democratic
strategic masterminds james ragin Cajun
Carville and Anita I don't know what her
nickname is but it needed done she's
awesome they're joining us right after
these words from our sponsors
with us now from Chicago Democratic I
just James Carville and from Gotham City
Barack Obama's former White House
communications director I needed done
thank you both for joining us and need
to start with you we want to run through
the people we think are on Trump's final
list here for potential V just tell us
the good and the bad in short of what
you think about each prospect starting
first with Anita what you think of the
prospect of Trump picking Mike Pence
well I think it you know it could
certainly help him carry Indiana perhaps
which you know that's the good right is
you know he's not exciting he's not you
know he's not dynamic and he had some
real negatives from his time as governor
so James what do you think of Pence is a
choice for Trump I think it helped a
Democrat carry Indiana he can't win the
governorship I help Trump weight
anything all right you're Bobby what
else my money is really good okay when
the governor's race are you gonna have
one how you can help win the presidency
all right so both these are like so
we've just do you guys think Ted that's
a bad idea give me your sense of what do
you think Christie would be a good
running mate for Donald Trump okay
christy is a good running mate for
Donald Trump if the only thing he ever
had to do in the campaign is to go
debate whoever the Democrats nominate
he'd probably do pretty well
unfortunately he brings his record he
brings his vet and he brings his
personality with him so I think that
outweighs his performance in debates all
right James do you think that's right i
mean that seems to me the defense a big
deal for already made you know if it's
up in it i mean he crushed marco rubio's
or you know most compelling moments in
history of presidential debates but
there's a lot of a lot of downside to go
with some potential upside and that
assumes that the Democratic
vice-presidential nominee can't get
ready for a debate which is a pretty big
assumption you know it's scary James and
I are agreeing this much sound so forth
yes you got it you've had a decade-long
relationship with your friend newt
gingrich i'm wondering having rejected
the first two options where they think
gingrich is a better choice than the
other two for Trump look if it took to
combine to prove
ratings in each of their states Georgia
New Jersey in Indiana I don't think it
add up to 75 and you know the
Republicans of its article and a tough
day about the deep bench and the talent
and the house multi-ethnic the party you
know the leaders laws and how young and
I mean I think this is a reflection of a
deeper problem that they have but you
know not gingrich's that gov is you know
aggressive guy like our guest Trump
thinks he could but tak he'll read and
give him some slack to do other things
that's ball out what I can think of you
know it's interesting because I actually
did have a number of really good
potential choices who either announced
very early they had no intention of
running with Trump or who Trump is
insulted you know susana Martinez for
example he called her the worst governor
in the country if i'm not mistaken no so
I I think that you know Gingrich
temperamentally is obviously someone
Trump is very comfortable with we do
think that's important i think is
important but you know nothing says
future like somebody who was speaker in
1995 so right i'm gonna guess work
personally do ya I think you don't want
us think that I think that's the only
one I think jeff Sessions would be I'm
going to guess the neither what do you
think jeff Sessions would be and it
particularly a stronger choice than
either of the first three we talked
about you know i i'm not sure what jeff
Sessions brings to the ticket besides
Trump's ability to say that he has
somebody in Washington who potentially
could help him with the legislature I'm
not sure that would stand up to scrutiny
but certainly judge sessions senator
sessions you know is someone that you
know Trump seems comfortable with as
well he's very partisan from a deep
south state that is not going to be
competitive so again he gives him the
ability to say he picked somebody yeah I
just think if you look at the people out
there talking about compared to what
we're talking about at the beginning of
the Republican Party if I'm a Republican
I have to be sick about the selection
done the choices I have a vice president
right now as I would be for president
but I kind of think that's obvious okay
more with the country duo of Carville
and done
right after this stay tuned back in just
a moment
you
back now with the two Democratic
strategist James Carville Hannah needed
done is a former White House
communications director for President
Obama guys last segment we talked about
Trump's VP options let's talk about
Hillary Clinton's the kind of
conventional wisdom remains tim kaine's
to lose leave Tim Kaine aside for a
second and nita you first what's another
name either out there or should be out
there that you think would be a good
alternative to Kane if she decides
against him well I've always been a fan
of Elizabeth Warren being on this ticket
I think the excitement of having two
women but also Elizabeth Warren who is a
great campaigner and who really connects
extremely well with voters who are
concerned about economic inequality I
think it would be a great ticket James
what's the name you like ah well i would
i would love it was born chris Christie
debate I think that'd be something I
would really love to see look I love
governor Kangas warranted terrific of
Sherwood brown Tom Vilsack oh but you
know the Castros that mean I think you
know I think she's gonna bottle think
we're going to know my guess is knowing
her she's gonna be very deliberate
listen to everybody read everything and
you know make up a mind somewhat later
but it's going to be pretty awfully go
wrong but I'm like Elizabeth if if he
picks chris Christie please pick
Elizabeth more hard but that vice
presidential debate be one for the ages
James James let me just stay with you if
you're thinking about about the running
mate selection as trying to address a
political problem or a vulnerability
what's the main political vulnerability
that Clinton needs to solve with her
running mate selection well i mean i
think if you look at the polls and
across the board that you know she's got
a you know show that that she's in it
for people as opposed to herself that
you know he's a larger motivation which
I obviously think that she does and you
know I think Warren would have some
stress there but you know a lot of you
got a lot of college-educated republic
instead of very very updates by voting
for Trump so she might want to go
in a different direction I think to stop
Admiral they were vetting up at Tufts is
this kind of interesting thing I'd I
don't know if that's a false flag
operation or whatever it is but you know
I wouldn't i wouldn't put something like
that you know pastor that she'd give it
a lot of consideration i happen to think
it's mark knows that the Democratic
coalition the presidential year is
sufficiently ascendant that if you unify
it it's pretty hard to win a loser
general election so if she can do that
with any of these picks I think should
be fine Anita what's your what's your
thought about that same question what
problem is she trying to solve or does
she need to solve well she is she
doesn't need to solve anywhere near the
number of problems Donald Trump does who
needs to solve for experience ability to
get a to get things done in Washington
foreign policy knowledge and basic
temperament and qualifications to be
President all of which I think are
unsolvable by his vice president no for
for Secretary Clinton she could go with
a candidate who's a younger generation
who could really send a message about
the future and also stronger together
diversity or as James said you know she
could she could look to somebody who can
help communicate that she really does
care about people which I like James
belief she does and that is somebody in
the economic sphere as sherrod Brown
Elizabeth Warren Tim Kaine is a terrific
guy a great campaigner fluent in Spanish
was in the Peace Corps has the kind of
experience in qualifications that people
look for and he would be additive as
well to the ticket at the end of the day
though it's who does she think should be
you know the vice president based on her
knowledge and her belief of who would
make a good president she'll make a good
choice James are you giving advice
directly or indirectly to Hillary
Clinton these days well Moe is given in
direct advice to anybody all the time
but I you know I thought you know I
think she's she's pretty pretty set on
you know going through each thing and I
just know her and I know she's going to
go through this and I think she's pretty
much going to be you know she'll listen
anything anybody has to say you know the
one thing that I do think that she needs
having run against both Bernie Sanders
and Donald Trump
they've got a little bit more on the
status quo side then then I think she
really is because how can you be more
changed in Donald Trump and did some
extent so I think of a vice presidential
nominee that would send a signal that
there's some change coming I think would
be very helpful and you know I don't
know how that plays out but I think it's
something they should consider Anita you
talked to a lot of Democrats and these
battleground state polls with John and I
talked about earlier in the program and
the comité announcement other things
what's your just sort of your your
overview of how Democrats are feeling
about the prospect of possibly losing to
trump in this race well I I think polls
that are done in July after you've had a
significant news event that was negative
or you know not exactly polls that are
predictive of what's going to happen in
November there's a lot of campaign
between now and then you know Trump was
artificially low at the end of June
based on possibly the worst month of
campaigning in distance okay i'm sorry
i'm asking is our people worried in the
Democratic Party now or now no I don't
think people are worried i think that
they understand it's going to be a close
race that we have to go out and win it
that we shouldn't be complaining
complacent we shouldn't take it for
granted i think democrats sometimes look
at trump and they think how could that
guy ever win and there's a complacency
that we should worry about these polls
maybe are a bit of a wake-up call it's a
tough race out there but I don't think
people are worried I think they look at
her and they see somebody who can you
know when the debates have a great
convention and basically you know head
on head against Donald Trump she's going
to win gee James in the wake of in the
whims of in the wake of last week in the
wake of Louisiana I know you're really
familiar with that state Minnesota and
Dallas and all the horrors of last week
Trump is light now playing the law and
order card sounds a lot like Nick's in
the nineteen sixty eight if that's smart
politically for him and is that
something Hillary Clinton's going to
have to counter more directly you know
now I was reading right for came on here
that he was saying that they were people
calling for a moment of silence for the
horrific shooter in Dallas and of course
no one can find any such thing I don't
think when people look I just find it
hard to believe in any
sense that when people are looking for
the country unified it was concerned
about all this that Donald Trump is the
go-to person this process and I mean are
you know I'm an adamant you know diehard
Democrat diehard Clinton supporter but I
mean I really mean that I just don't see
where he's playing this thing anything
close to the way that the country is
looking for this look at you know it's a
thirty-eight percent of country i'll
agree with him no matter what probably
so but i don't see anything that he said
that would expand at thirty-eight
percent at all neither we got just a
little bit of time left what do you
wonder about the republican convention
well I wonder what is the narrative
really going to be conventions or an
extraordinary opportunity to really
present your story the way you want to
present it and you know they haven't
given us any indication of what that's
going to be and so it feels like one of
the greatest opportunities he's ever
going to have to present his story the
way he wants to present it you know in
the question is can they rise up to that
occasion can they can they really use it
the way it should be used okay I needed
done James Carville thank you both good
to talk with you hey coming up we're
going to talk about the potentially
messy rules fight the looms ahead of the
Republican convention in Cleveland where
John is we'll be right back with that
and if you're watching us in Washington
DC you can now listen to us on the radio
radio at Bloomberg 99.1 FM more after
this
you
you
you
Republican convention rules committee is
scheduled to hold its first meetings
here in Cleveland tomorrow when those
never Trump delegates will try to free
themselves from the shackles a voting
for their party's presumptive nominee
joining us now to talk about what could
be a pretty ugly rules battle republican
attorney and MSNBC political analyst Ben
Ginsberg been good to see you we've been
talking about this it feels like four
weeks months like we're finally now
almost here and it seemed like the Trump
people thought they had this all under
control until a couple days ago we're
starting to hear maybe they're a little
worried so I think all of this is a
moving target I think delegates are
allowed to change their minds and
notoriously unreliable in terms of
giving hard counts at this stage the the
nominees whip team is right to worry
always and to operate as if the worst
could possibly happen they have a lot of
tools right so if you were looking at
the sit down but this situation that's
about to unfold over the course of next
2436 hours what are you looking for what
will you be paying attention to to see
to measure how it's going rules
committee meeting tomorrow the the
temporary committee of the RNC Rules
will run through the whole list of them
there are a number of tests rules that I
suspect folks will bring up to sort of
gauge strength and then they will
ultimately be the attempt to amend the
current rules to include the conscience
clause or the unbinding cause then what
what is you know what is propelling
things in the infection at this point
things then things are headed in a worse
direction which some rnc official
suggest is happening well I think it's
the uncertainty of things I think
probably picking the vice presidential
nominee if it's one that's reassuring to
the delegates is one of the things that
can move it in the right direction and
the indecision is sort of not helping
matters the fact that there is not a
convention program yet suggestions sort
of a roundabout
way that things are not buttoned up so I
think all those things are contributing
to the uncertainty that means when you
try and pin down delegates there perhaps
not rock-solid in what they're saying or
even worse just not answering their
phones all right so I know this is a
hard question to answer because the
delegates are in monolithic but if you
assume that the finalists for Trump's
running made our sessions pense Gingrich
and Christie does one of those stand out
to you as someone who the delegates
would say wow that's great Trump did a
great pick the convention is going to be
all excited for Trump and for running
mate X so I'm not I'm not certain I mean
I think that that each of them appeals
to sort of a different set of the
delegates so that's why the rip the whip
counts get so sort of tentative at this
point so I think each of the four has
both the strengths and weaknesses for
parts of the delegate pool again the way
that the republican party picks its
delegates is so state-by-state
idiosyncratic that it makes figuring out
which blocks there are of delegates to
go whip really challenging in a
situation like this so even if the Trump
people win on the rules matters that are
at that are in play it's also possible
that a minority report could be issued
out of the Rules Committee correct
correct and that would then open up a
floor debate over that authority report
correct it would so how messy could that
get even if they get over the big hurdle
tomorrow in terms of not amending the
rules in committee how ugly could it be
and chaotic could it be if that Minority
Report gets out there well arguing a
minority report in and of itself is not
necessarily messy I mean it's the
session runs under the rules of the
house there are minority reports all the
time in the house you put a strict time
limit on it under the rules probably
five minutes aside even if the rhetoric
gets particularly heated on one side or
another it's still five minutes in that
a vote what gets messy about it is the
length of time and the roll call
procedures for figuring out that vote
and it's also it's also sort of some
Chum in the water for the Sharks if a
minority report gets an unusual
large number of votes then there are
things to do beyond the conscience
clause that is going to be worrisome 22
I think the Trump whipped team right
then much much has been made about how
some corporate donors are not
participating in this convention some of
your fellow Republican activists and
strategists and consultants aren't
coming largely because of Donald Trump
in the end for a viewer for Republican
or independent around the country is
this you think going to come across
through media coverage and live coverage
like a usual typical Republican
convention or something different than
that and maybe not as good in terms of
impacting the chances of the ticket well
I could speak to the visuals and I think
the visuals don't reflect anything
different than what's happened in the
past the media coverage is unfortunately
way beyond my control to judge what's
actually written and said about that I
mean the one the one part where we're
not being there will matter is if on the
presidential roll call vote there are a
lot of Delegates who try and abstain and
don't come into the seats we haven't
talked about that that's not part of the
conscience clause but that's a place
where you would actually see an absence
of participation let me ask you a
broader question you prick inventions
many of them from inside the campaign's
nominees that are running them just from
your slight outside our posture this
time just judging the whole thing do you
think that the Trump folks people are
running this convention have their act
together so I think parts of it are very
much together i believe the whip team is
very together from what i've seen in the
platform committee and the the RNC
meeting today it is a whip team that's
acting very well and does have it
together it is unusual as you know from
your many years of covering conventions
not to have the program done not to have
announced the the keynote so that part
is unusual and does not feel like other
conventions yeah okay that's a that
seems I got very even-handed analysis by
our friend Ben Ginsberg thank you for
coming here and giving it thanks you'll
be back coming up we'll be back with our
his notebooks here in Cleveland after
this
you
you
here with us now in Cleveland for more
previewing of the Republican convention
next week Bluebird politics reporter
Michael C bendera animesh alcindor of
the new york times i think i said that
right it's great to see the two of you
meet you are you've report about social
justice and all kinds of really
interesting topics that it become
particularly pertinent of late talk a
little bit that open carry and the laws
that pertain in this state and what that
might mean for the security situation
that's the republicans are facing here
the open carry laws in ohio really mean
that they can ban stuff like a backpacks
are too big or water guns but they
cannot actually ban any handguns they
can't paint ar-15s they can't bend any
of the stuff that you can do so anybody
especially i should say anybody coming
from around the state ohio residents can
come carrying those weapons outside i'm
carrying them openly in a holster as
long as you can see them they don't need
a permit so basically what you could
potentially see is a lot of people with
a lot of guns and we can have them out
loaded or unloaded and a lot of people
are worried about that i wrote a story
about people kind of talking about the
idea that after Dallas people are really
worried that they're going to add to the
confusion of an already confusing
republican national convention we
passions were already high with Donald
Trump and now you have this so that's
basically with a law is the law is that
you can have guns out and be visible and
that's just confusion but fear and
paranoia and I know some of the groups
they're protesting or planning to
protest have said yeah we're going to
work we're coming we're gonna come
packing they there are groups so the
oath keepers is one of those groups
they're a group the Southern Water the
southern law poverty Center describes
them as kind of its really extremist
militant right group they say though
that they're there to really help
protect people to help the police
officers do their jobs in to kind of
basically shoot somebody if things get
out of hand I should say that there's a
pro Trump group that's having a really
big celebration rally on Monday and
they're saying that they're going to be
trying to ban people from long arm from
carrying long arms in there that's going
to be those rifles or ar-15 the problem
is though that the it's a little squishy
they do have a permit for the part they
can kick people out but you can just
imagine if someone has a loaded ar-15
teen strapped to their back you're
telling them not to come be able to come
into the park it's going to be really
hard yeah okay Mike Mike bender I just
talked about your general sense of the
Trump campaigns relationship now to the
RNC to the delegates in this event yeah
hi mark I've been talking to some
delegates and some RNC members around
the city who are here working on the
platform committee getting ready for
rules coming up here for the RNC meeting
and I'm very excited to be here in
Cleveland it's my hometown and it's an
exciting time but i'm not i'm not
getting the same sort of excitement from
from delegates and RNC members
particularly the folks are we putting
the platform committee together
yesterday i mean they have no they have
no reason to believe that Trump is going
to be campaigning on any of these issues
that they have spent weeks and months
assembling you know I mean Virginia Foxx
represent a Virginia Foxx from you know
was brought to tears yesterday after
after putting this platform committee
together and and there's just a
disconnect here between the delegates
and and the and their candidate I talked
to some folks who said you know we are
building our platform he's running our
campaign and that's just the way things
will be not a lot of real excitement
there and asking them about what we know
what they like about Trump a lot of
folks say well he's not Clinton I think
that can be an effective political
message I'm not sure how much excitement
that reflects though you mean she talked
a little bit more about the sort of
chain of command here you've obviously
got Secret Service you've got state of
law enforcement you've got the city just
talked about if violence does break out
if their protests I need to be dealt
with what's your sense of who takes the
lead on that and how things play out if
you get people actually arrested my
sense is that who takes the lead are the
Cleveland Police Department the
Cleveland Police Department I'm told by
several sources including a judge who's
going to be holding corp 20 hours a day
that he expects all the arresting
documents to be filled out by Cleveland
police officers he also expected that
the officers that are going to be coming
from as far away as California or
Florida that they're going to be coming
here and they're going to be
understanding that Cleveland Police
is the lead that they're going to be
following their procedures for mass
arrests there'd be following their
procedures for excessive force but I
should say that in this case the lead
Cleveland the police departments under a
consent decree so the Department of
Justice is watching this Police
Department because they were found to be
biased and they were found to to
repeatedly use excessive sports so the
issue is in some ways yes the locals are
in charge but ultimately the DOJ is
watching very closely bender I want to
ask you just because we were talking to
Ben Ginsberg a second ago about
delegates on the dump Trump folks that
delegates unbound what wait what are
they thinking right now they think they
have a chance to actually getting this
done or are they looking for some other
kind of like Pyrrhic victory yeah
they're what they're going to what
they're telling me is that it's mostly a
Pyrrhic victory and what they are going
to count as a victory is is if they can
convince people the education process
they want to talk about the process
which is that that that the primaries
are just a should just be a data point
and how they ultimately decide to vote
on the floor of the convention which is
to me an inherent flaw in this argument
has been from the beginning if you're if
you're trying if you're not for Trump it
seems to me like it have to be for
someone but they want to talk about the
process they want to talk about you know
how to have it you know pull the party
together and if it leads to someone
other than Trump great but hard to
motivate a lot of folks on process even
in Cleveland one-word answer whose Trump
gonna pick Gingrich whose trunk in
effect I think Ingrid's too okay Wow
gingras to gingrich's amazing Michael
beach Michael C bender and yummy shall
sindoor thank you and we'll be right
back
you
more of our coverage of the veep stakes
on both sides on Bloomberg pathak's com
any time we've also got a revised
Bloomberg politics newsletter you're
going to want to subscribe to go to our
website and you can subscribe there
check it out all right coming up on
Bloomberg TV Emily Chang talks to Google
senior policy council about combating
piracy beefsteaks continue tomorrow more
from Cleveland more on Hillary Clinton
meeting with Tim Kaine will have all
that for you tomorrow thanks for
watching sayonara
I'm mark Crumpton you're watching
Bloomberg West let's begin with a check
of your first word news leadership
officially changed hands today in the
United Kingdom Theresa May became
written second female Prime Minister
Queen Elizabeth invited her to form a
new government the Prime Minister wasted
little time appointing